let's bring in Kelsey night with Jamie
Fox News because last night he threw the
birthday party to end all birthday party
oh it went down Kevin and as you know it
has never publicly confirmed that he is
dating Katie Holmes but there is no
doubt now after the way they celebrated
Jamie's 50th look at that smile on
Katie's face the actors was beaming as
Jamie put his hand on her shoulder and
leaned in to whisper something into her
ear the clandestine couple were
surrounded by partiers but the two
seemed to be sharing a very happy moment
together
Jamie hinted that his birthday bash was
going to be special with this Instagram
video thank you so much for the birthday
wishes listen I'm about to turn up I'm
having a fantastic day celebrating my
family my friends that does so many good
things for me so many great things for
me the massive event was held on a
soundstage at Paramount Studios inside
the party Katie sat at a private table
with a baseball cap wearing Leonardo
DiCaprio he starred with Jamie in Django
Unchained
Leo's buddy Toby McGuire also attended
an actress Garcelle Beauvais posted this
pic with Jamie and his birthday cake
IceCube and Snoop Dogg took to the stage
to perform as did Jamie who has his own
hits and I witnessed lzt the birthday
boy sang a song with I love you in the
lyrics looking directly into Katie's
eyes
[Music]
you